share some tips for our entrepreneurs
that are tuning in from home I mean
there's so much number one let's talk
about people that are parenting
entrepreneurs something I'm incredibly
passionate about you've got a parent and
entrepreneur totally different
creativity is the core strength of an
entrepreneur the classic schooling
systems job is to put creativity into a
box I have a lot of empathy for the
parents that don't want their kids to
get D's and F's but I would highly
recommend the parents at home think a
lot about what it's required to do in
helping groom an entrepreneur which is
create more creative freedom because the
kid is spending time on X Y and Z is
gonna be okay to think about your grades
or the kids you went to school with and
how it worked out that's number one for
the entrepreneurs themselves content
content content the world is based on do
people know about your and your
entrepreneurial venture create content
at scale and here's the big one that
provides value to the audience you're
gonna see value put out content that's
good for them and then miraculously
things will happen for you